juillet c'est parti vous serez 7
millions sur les routes avec 7000
policiers 600 radar pour vous surveiller
en prit une essence sans plomb qui
grille la chronique le pouvoir d'achat
des salariés est resté stable de 85 à 88
en revanche progression substantielle
des revenus du capital et des revenus
des prestataires de services
le western chez le ferrailleur de
grenoble le père de la victime a été
longuement entendu par les gendarmes
le cinéaste lloris even c'est mort à 90
ans et est un aristocrate du film
documentaire
fasciné par la chine chantal beauchamp
convaincu de dopage la championne
française dette tag cloud est interdite
de stade jusqu'à 91
elle présente sa défense dans ce journal
madame monsieur bonsoir
avant de parler départs en vacances
parlons essence
l'introduction en france par les
pétroliers de nouveau carburant sans
plomb emmène en effet à se demander si
c'est moins polluants
quelles conséquences cette essence peut
avoir pour votre motard qui a intérêt à
la vendre en fait ce dossier de
l'essence propre entraîne une belle
cacophonie
patrice pelé philippe dumez
si un jour vous ne voulez pas faire
changer comme ici les soupapes de votre
moteur il va falloir faire très
attention à l'essence qui tous les jours
sert à professer votre voiture
c'est ce qu'affirme aujourd'hui certains
après l'arrivée sur le marché des
nouveaux carburants
le premier était baptisé heureux super
95 95 pour son taux d'octane c'est le
carburant obligatoire des voitures à
pots catalytiques
le second c'est le super 98 ce nouveau
super va remplacer l'ancien il est
destiné à toutes les voitures c'est de
carburant sont sans plomb et le problème
serait là car les moteurs de nos
voitures anciennes sont faits pour
fonctionner avec du plomb dans l'essence
et là attention la casse les héros super
sans plomb font courir des risques aux
moteurs lors il faut savoir qu'il ya
deux essence sans plomb
un heureux super 95 20 10 oct arles et
il y à 20 millions de moteurs qui sont
en danger de mort sur 22 millions de
véhicules deuxième type d'essence qui
vise à remplacer le super traditionnel
qui est l'euro super 98 octanes et là ce
sont 11 millions de moteurs qui sont
inadaptées et touristes la casse en
utilisant cette essence alors vous dites
que ces moteurs risquent la casse qu'est
ce qui se passe concrètement au niveau
de la mécanique vient c'est un effet
simple le plomb qui est utilisé dans
l'essence plombé à un effet lubrifiants
si vous supprimez cet effet lubrifiants
dans une essence sans plomb les soupes à
risque tout simplement de grippe et
comme lorsqu'il n'ya plus d'huile dans
un moteur et vous risquez la classe du
moteur les pétroliers de leur côté
affirment que leur nouveau carburant
sont bien faits seul un réglage de la
vence à l'allumage serait par exemple
nécessaire il n'y a pas de risque pour
les moteurs parce que on s'assure avec
un grand nombre d'essais d'abord qu'on
trouve des performances améliorées par
rapport aux carburants standard et
ensuite que il n'y a absolument aucun
inconvénient
à utiliser ces carburants là ont fait de
nombreux essais d'endurance conservation
dans les nouveaux carburants le plomb
pour l'aude renommée mondiale a bien été
éliminé en revanche aucune information à
l'heure actuelle sur la toxicité des
nouveaux gaz d'échappement résidus de
ces nouvelles essences 6 à la pompe
vous avez du mal à vous y retrouver pas
de panique des brochures sont à votre
disposition
à l'intérieur tout sur les
compatibilités essence voiture sur le
minitel fait le 36 15 suivi l'union de
la marque d'essence que vous préférez et
puis décidément si à tout ça vous ne
comprenez rien eh bien faites donc comme
d'habitude
prenez une bonne vieillesse ans à qui on
n'a rien retiré ni rien ajouté elle vous
donnera la joie d'une belle journée sans
panne effectivement et avec une bonne
nuit et sans doute serait sûr de rentrer
demain nous revenons sur ce dossier avec
la querelle qui oppose les pétroliers
les grandes surfaces justement sur cette
essence se sont l'exode
il a commencé pour les vacanciers de
juillet ce matin à lyon où il y avait
déjà 7 km de bouchon sous le tunnel de
fourvière
vous serez en fait 7 millions sur les
routes dont un million d'étrangers venus
de belgique ou d'allemagne c'est un
record
il ya bien sûr deux jours à éviter pour
partir demain et samedi attendait
dimanche la prudence aussi bien sûr
chaque année en france l'alcool au
volant tue quatre mille personnes ce
matin devant le tribunal correctionnel
d'evry un chauffard a été condamné à 18
mois de prison dont six mois ferme
son permis a été annulé l'amande et de
dix mille francs
parmi ses victimes il y avait un enfant
âgé de 10 ans son père estime que ces
sanctions ne sont pas assez lourde and
gas burget un homme seul un ter
qui n'en peut plus de retenir sa révolte
depuis un an pedro actionne attendait ce
jour de toute la matinée n'a pas cessé
de regarder fixement
l'homme par qui leur est arrivé hier à
la case 33 ans a tué parce qu'il avait
trop bu deux grammes d'alcool dans le
sang
oui j'ai fait une faute at il reconnu ce
matin j'avais bu trois verres de
champagne un ricard trois verres de vin
rouge 3 de blanc lors d'une fête
l'accident est effroyable sur
l'autoroute la bmw de la case percute la
deux chevaux des actionne à l'arrière il
ya une jeune fille et puis marine à 10
ans l'unique enfant de pedro toutes deux
sont tués sur le coup
circonstances banal a répété le
procureur mais un meurtrier ne doit pas
être un bouc émissaire
la case le regard vide écoute sans
jugement six mois de prison ferme
il en a déjà purgé deux ans préventive
six mois en prison
ça veut dire que par an voilà voilà ce
que ce que risquent les gens qui peuvent
tuer vos enfants 11 demain c'est de les
gens vont partir sur les routes pour
partir en courant et en vacances et les
voilà ce sont des actes ce sont des
homicides volontaires et on ne peut pas
légaliser le crime en france je le
voyais et c'est pas lui le voyais je
voyais ma fille
c est ma fille que je voyais sur lui
c'est pas lui
j'avais envie de sauter dessus mais je
voyais ma fille pedro actionner des
professeurs aujourd'hui il ne travaille
plus le père ne peut plus supporter de
voir ou d'approcher un enfant qui lui
rappellerait marina est aussi cet
accident spectaculaire près de
saint-omer dans le pas de calais il a
fait un mort et sept blessés
cette voiture attendait devant un
passage à niveau lorsqu'un poids lourd
de 35 tonnes a débouché à pleine vitesse
d'un virage en forte pente emboutissant
les voitures quatre véhicules ont été
propulsés sur la voie où rouler un train
de marchandises
un accident similaire s'était déjà
produit au même endroit en 1973 à champs
sur drac en isère l' enquête sur le
meurtre de david cyr ou 13 ans marquent
le pas le père et le frère de la victime
ont été entendus plusieurs heures
aujourd'hui par les enquêteurs
bruno roger-petit première inspection
sur les lieux du drame pour madame le
juge c'est revoir ce soir à 18 heures
information judiciaire ouverte c'est
elle qui a désormais la charge du
dossier cire ou un dossier de plus en
plus confus
ce matin il n'y avait pas de courrier
dans la boîte aux lettres des sirops
robert le père et étienne le fils revenu
après avoir été entendus la veille par
les gendarmes
robert l'ancien d'indochine le
légionnaire oublié par le monde sur un
terrain vague auquel il s'accroche
désespérément robert cyr ou en état de
siège
aidés par ceux qui cette semaine encore
monter la garde avec lui contre les
ennemis invisibles qui persécute sa
famille
il m'a dit jamais des chais plus
beaucoup de munitions et il faut
seulement que si tu peux encore quelque
chose si bien sûr c'est pas un problème
alors j'ai pris une boîte de cartouches
cartouches et j'ai foncé cartouches
calais 12 numéro 4 du calibre 12 contre
les ennemis invisibles ses ennemis
toujours désigné par robert cyr au lait
selon les selon qui veulent reprendre
leurs terres mais qui se terrent
toujours dans leur maison aux volets
clos et la haine est d'autant plus forte
entre les deux familles que l'amitié fut
longue entre robert cyr où l'ancien d'un
dos et marcel selon l'ancien de 14
noeuds patriat qu'on ne voit jamais les
deux été l'idée d'un super très
brad est très riche en distinction
monsieur selon et chevalier de la légion
d'honneur
si le sirop est un ancien légionnaire
qui s'est couvert de gloire mais une
amitié brisée pour des raisons inconnues
et cause de cette querelle entre deux
familles autour d'un terrain vague
pourtant ce soir rien ne permet au juge
servois d'établir un lien direct entre
la mort du petit david et la querelle
des six roues et des selon le pouvoir
d'achat des salariés ils sont 12
millions en france ce pouvoir d'achat
est stable c'est ce que révèle le
rapport annuel du centre d'études des
revenus et des coûts le cercle entre 85
et 88 l'augmentation des rémunérations
pour les salariés rémunération nette a
été inférieure à 0,5 pour cent en
revanche les revenus du capital
ceux des prestataires de services les
coiffeurs par exemple des commerçants
des professions de santé ont nettement
progressé
voici deux exemples extrêmes premier
exemple comment vit un couple de
smicards aujourd'hui reportage
d'elisabeth et gelé et françois granier
madame chikhaoui travaille dans une
imprimerie son mari soudeur mais
actuellement au chômage donc plus qu'un
salaire qui depuis quatre ans n'a pas
évolué et 4,25 gagné trois mineurs
maintenant 4300 alors les cotisations ça
remonte et la vie est plus chère
voilà actuellement vous avez combien
vous livrons font tout pour moi aux
mille francs grâce à leur banc oui ils
feront comme ça ça vient la fin du mois
auprès de mes employés
les crédits tout ça bon c'est ce qui
nous reste à faire c'est de recommencer
le moins 0 les salaires qui stagnent
il est ressenti comme une injustice
insupportable c'est parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas été augmentés depuis six
ans que monsieur chikhaoui acquisition
emploi et même au chômage il ne le
regrette pas à l'autre extrémité de
l'échelle sociale
un chef d'entreprise ces dernières
années l'ont fait accéder à la
prospérité
claire chazal créant 76 l'entreprise gel
2000 est aujourd'hui l'un des plus gros
distributeur de surgelés à sa tête guy
maheux quinquagénaire parti de rien car
son boucher nassian bull ans il est
devenu le 150e français le plus riche
car comme beaucoup d'entrepreneurs
hyperactif il a bien profité du récent
redémarrage de la croissance et des
allègements fiscaux en quatre ans un
chiffre d'affaires multiplié par deux un
bénéfice net multiplié par trois et puis
guillemassy aussi placer son argent en
action et tirer parti du boom de la
bourse
si je mets l'entreprise d'à côté jeu à
3700 francs l'action
savoir présenter sa 100 millions de
francs 510 millions à peu près
parallèlement à ça quand j'ai vendu les
actions et j'ai obtenu de l'argent et je
dois avoir une fortune qui doit être de
l'ordre de 16 millions de francs à peu
près comme ça sans quoi ce sont des
participations dans d'autres entreprises
tout à fait la plupart de l'argent que
j'ai quand j'en ai je mets dans des
entreprises dit me gagne environ 100
mille francs par mois
il en donne une partie au fisc mais il
ne s'en plaint pas vous savez je suis
bon joueur pour mon entreprise comme
pour moi même j'ai été très content
comme mon entreprise a commencé à payer
des impôts c'est qu'elle était rentable
au même titre à titre personnel si et
les abos parce que je gagne beaucoup
d'argent et je suis très content à m'en
payer ces deux exemples illustrent une
inégalité du partage de la croissance
qui ne peut laisser gérard leclerc
indifférente gouvernement oui si le
gâteau c'est à dire la richesse
nationale a grossi certains convives ont
été mieux servis que d'autres les
entreprises ont gardé pour elle même une
plus grosse part après les années de
vaches maigres leur épargne à progresser
c'est
autant de moins de distribuer aux
salariés mais c'est aussi cette
augmentation des profits qui a permis la
reprise de l'investissement et les
créations d'emplois
d'autre part les salariés notamment
smicards et fonctionnaires ont été
nettement moins gâtés que les
professions indépendantes ou les heureux
propriétaires de logements ou d'actions
politiquement c'est vrai ça pose à des
problèmes un gouvernement de gauche
mais la marge de manoeuvre est très
limitée c'est le ministre des finances
lui même qui prêchent la modération des
salaires pour ne pas relancer
l'inflation
quant à freiner les autres revenus le
gouvernement a commencé l'an dernier
avec les pharmaciens
il s'apprête à continuer avec les
médecins les biologistes et bien sûr les
propriétaires en limitant les hausses de
loyer mais il ne pourra guère aller plus
loin sans remettre en cause la liberté
des prix et déterré du même coup la
hache de guerre avec le patronat même
impuissance face aux revenus du capital
qui fiscalement vont bénéficier du grand
marché européen
là aussi la logique libérale se marie
mal avec la politique des revenus
merci gérard le déficit du commerce
extérieur en mai c'est mauvais il
s'élève à 6,6 milliards de francs il ya
bien sûr la hausse du pétrole mais ce
mauvais résultats illustrent une
faiblesse de structures de l'économie
française nous consommons trop de
produits importés
nos entreprises n'exporte toujours pas
assez nicolas jacobs les postes
frontières ont vu entrer encore plus de
marchandises étrangères que les mois
précédents
en revanche les douaniers ont rempli
moins de bordereaux d'exportation après
quelques espoirs en début d'année il
faut donc se rendre à l'évidence le
commerce extérieur français est en
pleine rechute
signe inquiétant l'essoufflement des
exportations est générale en particulier
celles de biens industriels
à lui seul ce secteur enregistre un
déficit de 6,6 milliards de francs il y
a cinq ans on notait le même chiffre
mais en excédent et là encore non
seulement les importations augmentent
mais les exportations chutent signe du
manque d'agressivité des industriels
français
il a suffi ce mois ci que les sauveurs
habituels comme l'agroalimentaire ou les
airbus fasse moins bien que d'habitude
pour qu'apparaissent déficit global de
6,6 milliards de francs le plus
important depuis août 88 depuis le début
de l'année la maison france a d'ores et
déjà acheté à l'étranger pour 14,3
milliards de francs de plus ennemi avant
et sans espoir de voir rapidement la
situation s'améliorait ce mauvais
chiffre a accéléré le mouvement de
baisse enregistré depuis trois jours à
la bourse
l'indicateur instantanée a perdu
aujourd'hui 1 37%
par ailleurs pour éviter les tensions
inflationnistes les autorités monétaires
française est ouest allemande resserrent
leurs conditions de crédit et relèvent
leurs taux d'un demi point
c'est le 18 juillet prochain que la
commission des opérations de bourse
examinera le dossier société générale il
pourrait y avoir dans cette affaire
délit d'initié et la cob travaillerait
sur plusieurs noms d'acheteurs suspects
dont celui de jean charles naouri ancien
directeur de cabinet de pierre bérégovoy
explications christophe martet toute la
vérité doit être connue cinq mois plus
tard le rapport de la commission des
opérations de bourse braque le
projecteur sur plusieurs personnalités
qui pour avoir bénéficié d'informations
privilégiées pour faire un coup boursier
sur la société générale
ce qui constituerait un délit d'initié
tout commence à l'été 88 georges
pébereau à la tête de mars aux
investissements prépare une opération
d'achat de titres de la banque
privatiser avec la bénédiction du
ministère des finances
pour cela il cherche l'appui de
plusieurs investisseurs certains
acceptent d'autres refusent
parmi eux l'ancien chef de cabinet de
pierre bérégovoy jean charles naouri
aujourd'hui à la tête d'une société
d'investissement néanmoins il va acheter
des titres société générale 10 millions
de francs au compte de sa société euris
et un million et demi de francs à titre
personnel
l'at-il fait à partir des informations
communiquées par georges pébereau il
s'en défend vivement en faisant valoir
qu'il a acheté des actions de la société
générale parmi d'autres sociétés
privatisées dont les cours étaient au
plus bas et qu'il a revendu ses titres
dès le mois d'août
bien avant que le cours ne flambent le
rapport de la cob site d'autres noms
d'investisseurs parmi lesquels les
pousses de françois dalle l'ancien pdg
de l'oréal et christian pellerin
président de l'asa riz qui tous les deux
ont participé au raid sur la générale
reste donc maintenant à la cob et à la
justice si elle est saisie de faire le
tri entre ceux qui seraient coupables de
délits d'initiés et ceux qui ont
simplement eu du flair
le rpr a officiellement demandé
aujourd'hui la constitution d'une
commission d' enquête sur la sphère
lüscher les juges qui ont été en charge
du dossier qui ont rendu une ordonnance
de non-lieu n'en finissent pas de leur
côté de s'expliquer par voie de presse
après le juge bezara l'est républicain
voici le juge le grand qui plaide non
coupable dans le nouvel observateur à
paraître demain
michel rocard le premier ministre lui
même avait rendu hommage à
l'indépendance du juge le grand hier à
l'assemblée nationale
commentaire hervé brusini le projet
viennent de toutes parts les vérités sur
la sphère lüscher vérité politique
d'abord
hier le rpr parler d'ingérence du
pouvoir dans le dossier ils demandent à
présent la constitution d'une enquête
parlementaire qui parlent d'ingérence
politique
pourquoi le gouvernement at il demandé
le placement de la sphère lüscher armes
en réponse le premier ministre
repoussé ces accusations en affirmant
qu'il n'avait aucun doute sur
l'intégrité du juge et juge le grand n'a
pas la réputation d'un homme qui se
soumettent aux pressions de quiconque
et s'il n'a rien trouvé c'est tout
simplement parce qu'ils n'avaient rien à
trouver et que c'est donc à tort qu'on a
fait le lien entre cette affaire et le
financement des partis politiques et le
juge ne dit pas autre chose car le voici
qui parle dans un entretien mûrement
réfléchie accordée au nouvel observateur
vérité judiciaire donc cette fois le
long dieu il ne l'a pas décidé pour
raisons de convenance dit il son choix
était arrêté avant même de savoir quelle
est l avis du procureur bézard au
chapitre financement politique via
l'exportation des obus lüscher il
rétorque je mets au défi quiconque de
trouver dans le dossier
un élément prouvant que de l'argent est
allé au parti socialiste
quant aux rapports barbares rédigé par
cet homme qui laissait planer des
soupçons rien des hypothèses répond le
juge le rapport a été exécuté en quinze
jours dans le contexte politique d'une
guerre des affaires finalement mettre en
cause des responsables étaient chose
délicate selon le magistrat daniel
dewavrin le pdg de lüscher a pu croire
dit-il de bonne foi qu'il était couvert
et le juge poursuit le ministère de la
défense n'a pas fait de tel pour
qu'éclate la vérité
celle de michel legrand en tout cas est
à présent connu sa publication n'était
pas un secret pour la hiérarchie du juge
apaise ratel les controverses nées dans
le monde judiciaire
c'est toute la question elle s'était
engagée à le faire l'association
française contre les myopathies rend
public l'utilisation des fonds
recueillis lors du dernier téléthon
organisé avec antenne 2 à la fin de
l'année dernière partisan de la
transparence les responsables de l'afm
présente des comptes détaillés des
dépenses engagées
stéphane magnier ces bâtiments de
l'hôpital de la salpêtrière n'aurait
peut-être jamais vu le jour sans le
téléthon 88 2000 m² de laboratoires
consacré à la recherche fondamentale et
qui ne représente que le dixième environ
des 189 et demi million de francs qui
avait rassemblé les missions dans kent
de l'an dernier les frais de reportage
de notre chaîne ainsi que les frais
techniques salaires loyers de l'afm
l'association française contre les
myopathies
on représentait 30 millions de francs le
reste a permis de financer 171 programme
de recherche et la formation de 60 des
étudiants de haut niveau qui travaille
désormais non seulement à la lutte
contre la myopathie
mais à combattre également d'autres
maladies neuromusculaires grâce au
téléthon l'afm est aujourd'hui à la tête
d'une croisade contre ces maladies
qualifiées d'oublier parce qu'elle ne
concerne qu'un petit nombre de victimes
ce sont tous ces enfants et leurs
familles qui ont reçu le plus 77
millions pour acheter des fauteuils
roulants des soins du personnel
tout ce qui permet de gagner du temps du
réconfort l'espoir bref au bout du
compte que ce soit la vie qui gagne à
l'étranger ce soir un dictateur ou rend
les bombes encore au liban et
l'assouplissement de l'embargo français
sur les ventes d'armes à la libye
éric perrin
l'envoi par la france au colonel kadhafi
de pièces de rechange de matériels
militaires respectent selon le ministère
de la défense l'embargo cette décision
prise au niveau du premier ministre et
du ministre des affaires étrangères ne
concernerait donc pas les armes
offensives
l'embargo sur la libye avait été
décrétée en 83 à la suite de l'offensive
militaire libyenne au tchad
reprise des bombardements à beyrouth
malgré les appels à la trêve lancés par
trois dirigeants arabes de violents
affrontements ont opposé sur la ligne de
démarcation
les troupes du général chrétien michel
aoun et l'armée syrienne
un civil a été tué et 15 autres blessées
doni o'brien le photographe américain
capturé le 8 juin en afghanistan
présentée à la presse internationale
o'brien était entré clandestinement avec
des moudjahidine en territoire afghan
il sera jugé pour espionnage ferdinand
marcos dans un état critique
l'ancien dictateur des philippines âgé
de 71 ans est hospitalisé depuis cinq
mois dans un hôpital d'hawaï pour des
problèmes cardiaques pulmonaires et
hépatiques marcos est actuellement dans
un état semi comateux
il avait montré dans de somptueux
document la chine
le cinéaste néerlandais et lloris events
est mort hier soir à paris c'était un
aristocrate du documentaire un cinéaste
engagé militant qui savait film est
aussi bien la pluie sur amsterdam que
l'image invisible du vent nicole cornu
langlois
on le surnommait le hollandais volant
parce qu'il était né à nimègue aux pays
bas mais qu'il avait parcouru le monde
entier avec sa caméra comme arme contre
toutes les oppressions
il avait consacré son oeuvre la plus
monumentale à la chine et son ultime
défi
une histoire de vent évoqué les mythes
légendes et métaphore de cette terre
d'élection
mais quarante autres films ont fait de
lui un maître incontesté du documentaire
poétique
au dernier festival de cannes il avait
participé au colloque cinéma et libertés
on vous le savez je suis né avec
l'invention du cinéma et d'aviation
aussi lors des violents mais après c'est
un événement incroyable pour vous jeunes
de vous se semble un homme du moyen âge
c'est quoi ce que j'ai bien connu est n
s'est arrêté dans son appartement quand
ils aèrent mexique et avec pudeur quand
on essayait à perugia faire et
l'international cinéaste faire existe il
a traversé le xxème siècle avec des
semelles de vent ont porté par les
grands mouvements de l'histoire
puis mais l'impasse et 20 cm dans ma vie
j'ai craint
il met l'impossible chantelle bojan et
malheureuse la championne française
dette d'heptathlon ça veut dire cette
discipline en athlétisme reconnu
positive lors des championnats de france
interclubs à tour le 28 mai dernier a
été suspendu pour dopage jusqu'en mai 81
l'athlète jure que tout cela est fou et
se défend sur antenne 2 gilles cozanet
je n'ai jamais pris de produits dopants
je suis j'ai passé des heures et des
heures depuis que j'ai 6 ans sur les
terrains de tennis à m'entraîner parce
que j'avais décidé de devenir une grande
championne j'avais la passion je faisais
des sacrifices depuis 10 ou 15 ans et en
me sacrifie comme ça sans même pas mais
c'est parler c'est dégueulasse voilà le
ton est donné chantal bojang des
meilleurs athlètes françaises elle fait
partie de l'élite mondiale de
l'heptathlon ni totalement l'acte
volontaire de dopage et met en cause la
procédure du contrôle qui aurait permis
n'importe quelle manipulation alors
chantal bojan victime d'une machination
de la fédération d'athlétisme
une hypothèse qu'elle évoque c'est vrai
que tout le monde pense que c'est j'ai
été la victime par rapport à moi je
crois plutôt que genghini team par
rapport à la fédération dont maintenant
pourquoi ils ont ils ont fait ça je ne
sais pas car menudo son entraîneur que
l'on voit à côté d'elle fut accusé par
notre confrère l'équipe de fournir des
anabolisants à ses athlètes anabolisants
comme le nom de ronald que l'on retrouve
aussi par exemple dans ce qu lire
inoffensive une hormone qui permet en
particulier s'il est pris à haute dose
d'augmenter la masse musculaire
un produit encore qui laisse des traces
très longtemps dans l'organisme
il semblerait que la substance que
j'avais dans le corps était récente donc
prises trois quatre jours avant avant le
le contrôle de tours comment suis-je si
idiote de prendre un anabolisant
trois jours avant une compétition où je
savais risquait d'y avoir un coût il
risquait d'y avoir un contrôle
et quand je sais que pendant le tout le
mois de juin
j'avais des meetings nationaux et
internationaux et je savais aussi qu'il
y avait et qu'il allait y avoir des
contrôles alors coupable ou pas coupable
le problème c'est que chantal bojan et
déjà condamné à wimbledon la française
catherine tanvier s'est qualifié pour le
3e tour en revanche quintrec à l'arrêt
suire ont été éliminés chez les hommes
victoire facile de becker en trois sets
quant à john mcenroe il a peiné face à
l'américain rheinberg jean le maire john
mcenroe a de nouveau connu quelques
passages à vide mais quand john devient
génial ça s'élève d'un temps john
mcenroe pour bien jouer doit vraiment
être monté sur ressorts bon pendant deux
sets il s'est oublié dans le troisième
avant de retrouver sa volée dans le
quatrième le tennis de mcenroe tout en
toucher peut alors s'exprimer
brain baird n'a fait que regarder quand
john mcenroe sert bien tout va bien
ajoutez à cela quelques coups de poignet
rapide a été fait et cela suffit pour se
qualifier
la forme de matière revient doucement
mais sûrement wimbledon s'est également
direct sur minitel 36 15 codes aequo à 2
des résultats des infos les biorythmes
des joueurs et un jeu de pronostics prix
mais vous avez encore un mois pour aller
relou pour admirer une partie de
l'oeuvre de michel-ange des esquisses
des dessins de toutes les époques
exposés sous la pyramide à droite en
entrant marie-josée le picard 7 tev
idéal cadeau de michel-ange à l'un de
ses amis ressemble à l'une des figures
de la chapelle sixtine artiste complet
mais quel ange se sert du dessin pour
toutes ses études d'architecturé de
peintures de sculptures ses études de
bras sous différents angles ont préparé
une sculpture peut-être celle de ce
jeune homme allégorie de la victoire
pour l'artiste qui prépare les oeuvres
définitif
les modèles dessinés sont presque
toujours des hommes quel que soit le
sexe des personnages qu'ils
représenteront ces distinctions qui nous
frappe aujourd'hui était beaucoup moins
importante à cette époque qu'à la
renaissance et il faut savoir que le
modèle qui posait dans l'atelier était
des sonates et des gardes faune et des
élèves des assistants de l'artiste
toujours des garçons le modèle femina
était interdite mais quel ange déjà
comme les architectes du xxème siècle
comme hoffman et wagner à vienne comme
le corbusier et mal et steve ince bas du
plan d'édifices à la commande
exact des pièces de marbre de
l'ornementation au mobilier intérieur
voici près de cinq siècles bien avant la
naissance des ordinateurs michel-ange
lui même disait le dessin est le seul
art et science existant sur tr dont tous
les autres des lives et font partie au
louvre jusqu'au 31 juillet c'est la fin
de ce journal dans un instant vous avez
rendez vous avec josé bien la pierre
pour la météo elle évoquera la grève va
la météorologie nationale qui se
poursuit dernière édition henri sannier
aux alentours de 23 heures 40 à demain
20h excellente soirée à tous sur antenne
oh